I will admit my most anticipated film of
the year is a sequel to Dune uh I think
Denise is amazing and I definitely have
to ask you what it was like working on
the sequel it was it was you've heard me
talk about the first film we've talked
about the first film uh it was that
times a hundred because it was Rabon
amped up and it was my part is much
bigger on this I got to spend much more
time with Denny which I crave for
because I love working with Denny
um and Denny again he just
Danny brings out the best in me and um
this was such an amazing experience and
I like I before I left the film and
we're talking about something else and
I'm not going to say until it actually
happens sure but he knows that my dream
is to work with him as a number one
because I really think that Danny will
show me how good I can be
um
but
this is so amped up from the first film
the first film was just an introduction
to what this film is there's just so
much going on that's so
it's so much more Cutthroat and
political and intense and there are
actually you know there are moments of
levity where there are some funny
moments and they're kind of absurd humor
but uh there are those moments so it's
just so much more amped up than the
first film
um Greg Frazier shot it uh the sequel
like he shot the first one um I spoke to
him he seems very he's very happy with
how it turned out can you talk a little
bit about because I think his
cinematography is one of the reasons
those films are yeah why it's so good
yeah he's amazing and I love him as a
human being he's just a lot of fun he's
one of those people he's
is really intense uh when he works he's
definitely focused but he's also he's
such a I think he's so talented that you
can just break away from it and just
take a second and just have like a fun
conversation and just talk about nothing
you know you can step away from his work
for a minute and just have a stupid
conversation about you know the funny
something funny you saw last night you
know but and I love that about him yeah
yeah
um also he did the Batman I mean the
list of what he's right it's it's and he
talks about the way I see that and the
way we put that on a pedestal and he
talks about it like yeah you know yeah a
very another day at the office